over the years I've had a number of
clients students friends and colleagues
and even people who've just reached out
to me who were troubled by buying into
some sort of philosophical point of view
or position or claim or assertion that
they didn't need to necessarily do that
with and then you know being quite upset
or making bad decisions on the basis of
thinking that that was true and and not
just true but
unassailably true or true in a sense
that they had to follow it and you might
say well that's very abstract what are
you talking about here let me give you
one prime example so I had a
philosophical counseling client who came
to me because they were very worried
about the non-existence of Free Will and
what the implications of that were for
their own life and you know maybe others
have gone through this who are watching
this and this this guy's case he had
been you know listening to a lot of
podcasts and I won't actually name the
person who had made these sweeping
assertions on the basis of Neuroscience
that there was no such thing as free
will but this person bought it and they
were very troubled about the
implications of it and I you know
ignored the easy low hanging fruit fruit
of saying well I guess you're just
determined to be bothered by that you
know and I'm equally determined to try
to see if I can help you out with that I
I didn't take that sort of tack instead
I asked one central question which we're
going to reiterate at the end
how in the hell do you know that person
is actually right and how would they
possibly know that there is no such
thing you know with such a degree of
certitude that they can make this
absolutely
unequivocal
apodictic sweeping assertion for all of
us now what I advocate is not just
throwing everything out but you know a
healthy skepticism about these sorts of
very big philosophical claims about you
know whatever you want it to be the
existence or the non-existence of God
whether there is free will or not and by
a free will people mean a million
different things right so you always
gotta clarify you know are there
different uh fundamentally different
mentalities in men and women or in
conservatives and police and and
liberals or pick whatever else you want
people make these really really broad
claims quite frequently and you know
it's uh it's not something radically new
this has been going on for Millennia
um but I think that it's a more pressing
problem now in our Internet's
um whatever you want to call it infused
infected age in which you have the
possibility of getting all sorts of
people's ideas essentially thrown at you
on Moss with links to everything else so
easily so
what is common to these kinds of claims
let's think about that first I actually
as I was considering this I came up with
a four main characteristics that this
might be helpful for you to you know
think about whether you or somebody else
that you know is buying into these sorts
of ideas so one is that these claims
wind up being made at a very high level
of generality oftentimes they're framed
in Universal terms everybody nobody you
know all humans All Humans of this sort
All Humans of this sort there's a kind
of totalizing of the the universe that
goes on with this we're talking about
really really big stuff and big claims
that goes along with that and you know
another thing is that these are claims
and positions that are made about
matters that for you know a long time
have been the province of philosophy not
exclusively so like you know does life
have meaning or not well philosophy has
a lot to say about that so does
literature so does history so do other
you know important
um Arts Sciences whatever you want to
call them disciplines we could say
whether you know all things are
determined causally or whether there are
uh you know some scope for human freedom
and and a faculty that we call the will
that that's you know a matter of
psychology that can be a matter of other
things as well but that's definitely
within the province of philosophy so
when we start to see people talking
about these really big Ideas you know we
should we should be a little bit
suspicious especially if they try to
make claims like you know philosophers
have argued about this for hundreds of
years and never made any progress that's
a philosophical Claim by the way
metaphysic philosophical claim
um and you know we're going to solve it
with this instead people have been doing
that for hundreds of years quite frankly
we'll do another video about that some
other time so those are two
characteristics the Third
is that what we see people doing
typically
is over simplifying
you know a lot of people love
dichotomies you know some people are
like this and other people are like this
or so I'm thinking is slow and some
thinking is fast or you know and and
they throw these things out there as if
it's that simple
typically it's not
and we should be a little bit leery of
anybody who is using a lot of over
simplifications typically drawn from
other people I suppose it's worse when
all the oversimplifications are coming
from their own weird quirky Theory but
we should be you know on our guard when
we see people
making claims where the parts are very
very clear and distinct and
um you know they probably don't have
that that real nature and then the other
part is that these claims tend to be
asserted I was at first tempted to say
with a high level of confidence but we
don't actually know what's in the other
person's mind could be that they
actually don't really believe it but
they're asserting it so that they can
get you know followers or clout or money
or something like that build themselves
a name
certainly they're giving the appearance
of being very confident about what it is
that they're saying so we see people
coming on and saying there's obviously
no such thing as free will and you're
like whoa that's
how do you actually know that to such a
degree of not just confidence but
absolute certainty as to enunciate it
like that so these four different claims
kind of are four different
characteristics of claims that that
might be helpful for you in thinking
about it what are the kinds of claims
that people are making or where are
these claims coming from so a big thing
is like pop psychology you know what we
mean by popular psychology where people
have got some ideas they're they're
taking from some psychological theory or
it could be evolutionary biology or it
could be Neuroscience always be on guard
when somebody makes claims about
Neuroscience because some Neuroscience
is really science and some of it is
absolute junk and there's everything in
between don't take it for you know uh
take it on confidence that somebody
invoke talking these things
automatically knows what they're doing
so popularizations of scientific matters
coming perhaps from the Natural Sciences
or the social sciences or from other
fields as well you know we see people
doing bad history of ideas uh quite
often relying on some sketchy sources
that had axes to grind and then you know
coming out with a whole book about that
that sort of thing so that's one uh
origin of these sorts of claims
scientists who stray outside of their
fields outside of their disciplines
outside of where their training was
outside of their areas of competence
very common right if you see somebody
who's a great scientist claim that
philosophy is dead you know they're full
of crap at that point because they don't
actually know they usually they haven't
done the the requisite study or reading
and they're just opining it's sort of
like listening to a plumber wanting to
you know tell us about which Symphonies
are the best I mean if they're out
actually a trained musician or they've
done music history now we're not
listening to them as a plumber we're
listening to them as that but that's not
usually the case
um
a third one I mentioned bad history of
ideas there's a lot of people out there
peddling you know very schematicized
readings on the history the very
complicated history of ideas a lot of
bad histories of philosophy out there
sometimes coinciding with the pop
psychology sort of stuff and you you
don't want to take that stuff just on
the credit that the person has written a
book anybody can write a book these days
anybody can publish a book Amazon
self-publishing you can also find lots
of really mediocre poorly researched
stuff coming out from reputable presses
that maybe shouldn't be so reputable
anymore you actually have to look
closely at what the person is saying and
then finally the last thing that I want
to mention in here this may seem like a
bit of an outline there but I think it
really can be helpful in this respect
when philosophers big name philosophers
give a take on some other philosopher or
a philosophical school or movement or
something like that
they it's not always right
prime example of this somebody who I do
a lot of work on Hegel right
hegel's a very interesting author he's
got this interesting systematic approach
to not only the mind but history and all
sorts of cool stuff but he's not a good
historian of ideas
sometimes he's insightful but a lot of
times he gets stuff wrong
you know and we can say similar things
people bring up you know for example
Nietzsche's takedown or critique of
stoicism in Beyond Good and Evil
well nature could be wrong how do you
know that because this guy over here
said something that this over here is no
good valueless right you don't actually
until you go and you study the object of
critique similarly we could say you know
we're talking about a lot of German
philosophers here Arthur schopen our
says some really stupid things about
Hegel and should you let schopenhauer's
dismissal of Hegel as a charlatan
dissuade you from actually studying
Hegel or taking him seriously you'd be
kind of a fool to do so wouldn't you
without actually checking up on whether
schopenhauer's critique is actually
correct
um now why does this matter
so you know we should care about
actually getting things right
um not endorsing and reproducing and
disseminating false ideas
that's important for us as human beings
as truth seeking creatures right so you
know we should call out falsity and
deception and lying and sloppy
scholarship and stuff like that but
there's some other really important
reasons going Beyond this the first of
which is as I pointed out I actually do
encounter people and talk with them uh
about this this issue sometimes people
will you know see a claim being made and
they will believe it and then they'll be
like holy crap this changes everything
for me if there is no free will you know
then what happens how should I look at
moral responsibility what about my own
actions am I just merely automaton and
this causes a lot of people trouble
anguish anxiety anger all sorts of
negative affects and emotions so if you
don't want to have those caused by the
ideas
it might be helpful to look whether the
ideas are actually grounded in anything
whether these claims have any genuine
basis to back them up or whether it's
mere assertion sometimes people make
decisions or judgments based on these
sweeping
ultimately you know they could be true
but probably are false sorts of claims
and wow you know like if you're going to
run your relationship life based on what
some Guru who happens to have a podcast
is telling you and you're uncritically
accepting it you might screw your life
up and so that that's a significant
problem another thing is you know
there's a
there's something weird about giving
people
as we say brain space or room in your
mind rent free
you wouldn't just take in anybody as a
roommate would you but you check them
out first don't you you do like an
internet search and maybe even a
background check well why would you do
that for somebody who's written a book
or has a podcast or you know is putting
ideas out there in some other way why
wouldn't you verify uh whether they're
actually right before you give them some
of your valuable real estate in your
mind and then you know the other thing
that I'll mention and again this is in
in part it's not a product of the
internet age but it's exacerbated a
little bit with the internet age
you can easily find communities of True
Believers who buy whatever it is that
this person has to say
and they will be like a reinforcing uh
feedback loop that you don't want to get
caught in because they're buying that BS
it doesn't mean that you have to but if
you want to hang out with them if you
want them to be part of your life and
them to be part of yours you kind of
have to drink their Kool-Aid in order to
do that and what if you start finding a
bad taste in your mouth when drinking
that Kool-Aid just drink some more and
it'll work out that's a sign that you're
not really in a community of free
thinkers or anything you're in something
like a cult
so you know these are all some important
considerations now what what practical
advice do I actually have I've done a
lot of charting out what the problem is
I think that we should events some
healthy skepticism I don't mean the kind
of skepticism that says I can't know
anything I distrust everybody no
hyperbolic silly uh skepticism even
Descartes says that's just a method
that's not where you want to keep on
living right but healthy skepticism
saying well how how do we know this
what's the actual basis for this so you
know when it comes to claims that you
think you're stuck with because you
heard somebody else telling you them or
you read them somewhere ask yourself
well how do I know that this is actually
the case and that'll be very helpful for
you that's a habit that you should get
into you don't have to do in a combative
way you don't have to be like you gotta
prove it to me man you'd just be like I
want to you know have some good grounds
for accepting very general statements
that I might use to actually run my life
and make decisions and structure the
work that I'm going to do and and you
know understand my relationships but you
can also turn that on these people and
you can say
how would they possibly know these
things that they're saying if somebody
wants to make a claim that there is once
again with the free will there is no
free will whatsoever in the universe
definitely not with human beings this
has been proven you can say well how in
the hell would you know that
have you actually like peered into the
the head of every single human being
throughout history all the you know
billions of people on our planet Debbie
have you done that sort of work no well
you looked in a few MRI machine things
and you did a few experiments oh that's
interesting so you didn't really
actually you didn't really accumulate
the kind of data that would justify a
sweeping claim like this right if people
want to make really you know
wide-ranging claims they got to have
really really good evidence that
addresses every single possible loophole
before you can buy it I mean if they
want to hedge their bets and say well
probably or it's likely that now those
are weaker claims right and they don't
have to have quite as much to justify
that but they still have to be able to
justify it they still have to be able to
say where they got this privileged
Viewpoint that we all should buy into so
a skepticism towards them I think it's
also very important to take account of
your own experience and to experiment
with ideas in life that's not to say
that you know personal experience trumps
everything but it does count for
something right and this extends not
just to experiencing things in the world
but your experience of reading and
thinking you are a rational being just
as much as any pop you know culture
person out there who's got a million
followers is they're not more rational
than you
so you know you can use your faculties
to think these things through and you
have the right to say yeah I don't know
if I'm gonna buy that right now that's
an interesting hypothesis you're
proposing but I don't see enough there
to compel me
um you know you should be
um
skeptical about these these kinds of
arguments you have the freedom to do
this and I'm going to teach you
something from the ancient Skeptics
they talked about for every argument for
every claim with evidence being provided
you could oppose to it another argument
and this is not just a game this is not
just to knock things down it's to buy
you a certain space of freedom
to think these things through
skepticoi means Seekers those who are
actually looking for what would be true
the last thing I'll say is you know the
world and human nature incredibly
complex right so anybody who wants to
say that these things are simple and
straightforward that should probably be
a red flag to you right off the bat we
need to continually keep thinking and
learning and Discerning and judging and
sometimes you know saying oh I made a
wrong turn I need to come back over here
that's the way that things work for
truly rational beings as rational as we
can be so if you're the kind of person
who does have a tendency to buy into
these bombastic claims that typically
get made within the field of philosophy
sometimes by philosophers sometimes by
other people maybe this is helpful for
you
um maybe there's some interesting
examples that you'd like to bring up or
discuss in the comments and I hope that
you know if it hasn't been helpful at
least is thought provoking and
interesting for you